well today's figures do show that the
economy is experiencing a very strong
recovery fastest growth in the g7 group
of countries and evidence that our plan
for jobs is working but i'm not
complacent the shock that the economy
and our public finances have experienced
has been significant and it will take us
time to fully recover and that's why i'm
not done supporting businesses or people
and most importantly giving them the
skills and the opportunities they need
to find great jobs but more specifically
on the barriers to recovery i mean for
example would you say that we've
squandered some of our potential vaccine
dividend this summer because we've been
very cautious over things like travel
and isolation rules well on travel i
know the sectors had a very difficult
time but they've benefited from almost 7
billion pounds of support from start to
finish through this crisis and most
importantly over the past few weeks
we've been able to cautiously reopen
travel
for double vaccinated passengers and
that is an enormous boost to the sector
would you vote it sooner it was right
that we do these things in a measured
way and that's what we've done taking
advice as we go but now that we can see
you know a safe reopening of the travel
sector that will be an enormous boost to
them and hopefully safeguard many more
jobs obviously your priority will be
sustaining this recovery but there are
some big policy commitments coming up
that need to be funded not least social
care uh funding our climate change
commitments
how exactly are we going to pay for all
that given that the economy absolutely
is still recovering
well the economy is recovering and it's
recovering well i think when it comes to
the spending review over the the autumn
which we will do
what we're going to see is absolutely no
return to austerity people are going to
see very strong investment in public
services over the course of this
parliament for context by the end we'll
be spending 100 billion pounds a year
more every year than we did at the
beginning that's why we're going to be
able to have 50 000 more nurses 20 000
more police officers 40 new hospitals
and roll out things like broadband
across the country to spread opportunity
and and that's what we were elected to
deliver and that's what we're getting on
and doing but there are some big numbers
you know climate change alone 1.4
trillion pounds and it's time to level
with the taxpayers surely about whether
they're footing that bill well i know
people people will look at these numbers
and they will have concerns about what
that means so then what the government
is committed to doing is making sure
that we do the transition to net zero in
a way that does keep costs low on people
and what i'd say is look at our track
record over the past uh a couple of
decades we've grown the economy 75
and at the same time we've cut carbon
emissions by almost half so that shows
it's possible to do both things we can
become more prosperous as a country more
jobs more successful businesses more
money in our pockets whilst also
becoming greener and that's what we need
to do going forward as well the prime
minister and yourself are clearly
neighbours you live next door to each
other are you friends
yes we are
do you think we can afford all of his
promises yeah i think we're the prime
minister and i absolutely united in
making sure that we deliver on the
commitments we made to people that we
invest in public services that we spread
opportunity around the country but in
the short term we're united in making
sure that our economic recovery is as
strong and as quick as possible and
that's what my focus is and the numbers
today
show that my plan for jobs is working
and that is happening
the pandemic has clearly hit the poorest
the hardest and we know that and in the
last week we've seen fuel prices are
rising off gem raising the energy price
cap
and the poorest and most likely to have
worked through their savings as well
what are you going to do to ensure that
this recovery is fair
well one of the things i'm proudest of
over the past 12 to 18 months is that we
have looked after the most vulnerable in
our society and all the figures show
that those on the lowest incomes have
seen the most support from this
government at what has been a very
difficult time and we're not done
supporting people my firm belief is the
best way to help those families is to
make sure that they can have well-paid
work and we've got a suite of things
that we're doing the national living
wage is going up we're also helping them
with new skills training to find better
jobs the kickstart scheme where the
government is fully funding high quality
jobs for young people at risk of
unemployment those are the types of
things we're doing and they will all
make a major difference extending that
temporary uplifting universal credit
though is clearly going to help the most
why won't you do that no i don't think
that will help the most that temporary
uplift was indeed temporary it was the
right intervention for the particular
part of the crisis that we've
experienced but now as the economy is
reopening and businesses are hiring
again the right thing to do is to help
people find really well paid jobs which
is why the kickstart scheme is important
it's why we're giving companies huge
cash incentives to create new
apprenticeships for people and it's why
the prime minister's lifetime skills
guarantee is crucial 10 million adults
who don't have a level 3 qualification
will for the first time be able to get
one from the government we know that
that can have a transformative impact on
people's ability to get a new job or get
a better paid job those are the right
ways to help people i know you're keen
to get people back to the office can i
ask how much of the proportion of the
staff who work here at the treasury are
back to the office at the moment yeah
well we're making good progress i was
actually just hosting coffee with a
bunch of recent graduates who've joined
the treasury over the last six to 12
months and all of them are excited to
slowly and carefully be coming back to
the office and that's very much the
government's guidance you know we're no
longer instructing people to work from
home and it will be up to employees and
employers to make those decisions for
themselves and what we expect is a
cautious and gradual return to the
office